اغنى قاره في العالم بالثروات وافكرها
اقتصادا افريقيا مطمعا طبعا والوصول
للكنوزها الطبيعيه هدف لكن الطرق تختلف
الصين اختارت ان تميز نفسها عن الدول
الغربيه والمستعمرين السابقين تريد
المنفعه المتبادله بدلا من الارتكان الى
وسائل المنح
سياسته سياسه تبدو ناجحه ان علمت ان بكين
يتوقع ان تجني من افريقيا
440 مليار دولار بحلول 2025 جنوب افريقيا
واثيوبيا في المقدمه مبلغ يعادل نصف قيمه
عرس الميزانيه الخاصه ببكينا لهذا العام
تريليون دولار وهنا تظهر ضروره التغيير
واشنطن سياستها من علاقه صفه الابويه الى
علاقه شراكه والمستفيد الاول هنا هو دول
القاره قادتها يريدون علاقات جيده مع كلن
من الصين وامريكا لكن سياستها بكين بدات
تتغير اصلا مؤخرا تجاه لعسكره السياسه
الخارجيه وواشنطن قلقه من ثمان النفود منذ
2017 لدى الصين قاعده عسكريه لوجستيه في
دره تاج القرن الافريقي وقلبي مشروع
الحزام والطريق في جيبوتي التي تعد بوابه
قناه السويس التي يمر عبرها عبرها 10% من
صادرات النفط العالميه وعشرين في المئه من
السلع التجاريه
نافعا اخر لواشنطن لاستدراك الغفله عن
القاره القاعده لا تقع فقط على واحده من
الممرات الاستراتيجيه الرئيسيه وهي اكثر
ممرات الشحنه البحريه ازدحاما بل تبعد
ايضا سته اميال فقط عن قاعده عسكريه
امريكيه رئيسيه وهنا هو من جيبوتي يظهروا
اللاعب اخر مهم تراجعات نفوذه في القاره
والصور نمطيه مختلفه تماما عن الصين نتحدث
عن فرنسا تمتلك في جيبوتي اهم واقدم قاعده
عسكريه لها في القاره فرنسا البلد
الاوروبي الاكثر ارتباطا اليس بجبوتي فقط
بل بافريقيا كامله عقودا من الاستعماري
والاستغلال غادرت بقوتها لكنها باقيه من
وراء الستار بعملاتها الفرانك الافريقي
بالعوده لعام
1945 فرنسا قررت انشاء عمله موحده تدير
بها مستعمراتها في افريقيا حكم الواقع
الاستعماري اينما كان جاء الاستقلال بعدها
لبعض الدول نعم تخلصت من الاستعمار بحلول
عام 1960 لكنه كان اكذوبه الامر لم يتغير
14 بلدا افريقيا يواصل استخدام الافريقي
حتى
دول افريقيا رغم نجاحها في تشكيل الاتحاد
الاقتصادي في
1975 الا ان كل المشاريع الانفصال المالي
عن باريس ذهبت هباءا كيف تستفيد فرنسا اذا
من هذا الامر البنك المركزي الفرنسي يطبعو
الفرانك مقابل رهن الافارقه ل 50% من
احتياطاتها النقديه ملايين الدولارات
مجمده في باريس وبالتالي الدول الافريقيه
الفقيره مضطره لتحويل اربع حصادراتها الى
اليورو اولا وهذا ما يساهم في سد العصر
الماليه الفرنسيه وحتى فوائده الاموال
المدعه لا تحولها فرنسا نقدا نقبل تمول
بها فنادق فرنسيه في افريقيا يبقى سؤال
اخر لماذا لم تتخلص ادول غربي افريقيا من
عمله الاستعمار فرنسا لن تقبل بخساره
النفوذ مين لن انشات عملتها لكن باريس
طبعه اموالا مزوره لتدمير عملتها الجديده
والعهده على كتاب الاسلحه الخفيه لافريقيا
الفرنسيه مثال اخر في توغو رئيسها الاسبق
انتقد الفرانك الافريقي والنتيجه كانت
اغتياله عام
1963 اين داخل السفاره الامريكيه ومن كان
المتهم الاول الاستخبارات الفرنسيه وذلك
باعتراف احد المنفذين